maintenant comment cuite au delà yeux du
jeune agneau comme ceci vous êtes lui
avais four à 375 à 400 et les mêmes
important d'avoir un thermomètre a bien
bien a perdu les thermomètre à viande ne
date pas d'hier mais leurs fonctions ont
bien évolué
l'épicerie a mis au banc d'essai 12
modèles parmi les plus représentatifs et
les plus populaires nous avons choisi
ceux qui suivent la cuisson en continu à
l'intérieur du four
ça a été des jeunes c'est avec des gens
vont un peu comment ça fonctionnait
s'habituer ou son mode de fonctionnement
de programmation et cetera mais aussi je
voulais voir des paramètres de
précisions on a mis dans un bain ou très
très précise dans un thermoplongeur à 60
degrés on a fait aussi un coeur 0 à st
donc de zéro degré celsius dans une zone
très glacée jusqu'à 1oo bouillante un
grosse émission
bonne nouvelle tous les modèles sont
précis le chef les a ensuite testé avec
des rôtis de boeuf de porc et des
poulets dans les cuisines du lit thq de
façon à identifier ces trois modèles
préférés moratti il y a quatre familles
de thermomètre d'abord les modèles
analogique à ressort bien qu'il soit
simple et fiable ils sont parfois
difficiles à lire et nous oblige à
ouvrir la porte du four
ensuite les thermomètres à son fils
errent reliés à une base à l'extérieur
du fou de loin la catégorie la plus
populaire avec plusieurs modèles vont
suivre en temps réel
digital la progression de la cuisson en
plus on n'ouvre pas le faut parce que
c'est à l'extérieur comme le doc de
thermo world le préféré de notre chef
qui était très très très simple car
aucun pré programmation donc il faut
connaître cuisson pour ça il ya un seul
bouton qui disait qu'on va nous mener
et on fait juste régler la température
maximale ce qui était bien aussi sur ce
modèle là c'est le fils qui est très
solide
donc j'ai pas peur de le briser
alors que certains produits offre
uniquement d alarme lorsque la
température est atteinte d'autres
offrent des prix programmation avec des
températures de cuisson selon le type
devient donc pour les gens qui sont un
petit peu plus néophytes ben ça permet
d'avoir une lecture sans ce cas c'est la
taille puis consulter des livres 7
internet pour trouver la bonne
température
mais il ya des paramètres qui sont un
peu plus élevés qui sont certes au point
de vue il note 8 et alimentaires
béton mais au niveau du goût ça va me
donner bien trop qu est un peu
arrosée comme on le mange en europe
alors là vous ferez cuire jusqu'à
370 à 406 vous l'aimez à l'anglais de
cycle beaucoup moins bon alors là vous
le faites jusqu'à 450 ou la maison je
trouvais qu'elle vainc action qui est
intéressant c'est leur écart d'eau en
terme de programmation de degré de
cuisson vous l'avez tous vu comme un
signe pour moi c'était celui qui était
le plus intéressante dans tout l'eau on
avait des températures de cuisson qui
était assez réaliste pour un
professionnel le fils très très très
très très longtemps donc peut être un
avantage ou un inconvénient
dans un boîtier presque identiques ou
ricardo le modèle et skalli a déçu il
est pauvre bilingue le sk ligne et aussi
au niveau des températures les
températures sont beaucoup plus élevés
dans les programmations donc là on
aurait vraiment des rôtis doivent passer
assez grisant
71° celsius
autres catégories les modèles avec un
récepteur sans fil le modèle à qtel a
impressionné mais n'y étaient faciles à
contrôler les lectures étaient très
bonnes
une bonne portée presque 100 m
à l'extérieur de la maison
on va savoir quand est-ce qu'on perd le
signal
c'est quand même ce qui justifierait que
ce soit si loin de mon faux je sais pas
en fait catégorie de plus en plus
présentes sur les sites d'achats en
ligne les thermomètres dits intelligents
comme le miteux et le web
il ya aussi des modèles à travers une
application dans votre iphone
intelligent vous permet de suivre en
temps réel et enregistre aussi les
cuissons sans être dans les préférés du
chef le mieux avec son petit boîtier de
recharge en bambou a bien impressionné
on est dans quelque chose qui est tout
petit comme ça
deux façons de prendre une mesure ça
c'est qu'on peut prendre la mesure
interne dans l'avion avec le hezbollah
et le bout en céramique
par contre la sonde résiste un maximum
de 2 175 degrés celsius qui peut être
facilement dépasser si on cuisine au
charbon de bois on est à 59 actuellement
la température du poulet on est à 67
dans le faux en plus nous laisser savoir
que notre barbecue est en panne en
mesurant la température ambiante
l'application calcule une période de
repos après cuisson pour la viande pas
pour le chef
on y vit 60 dans les températures étant
continue d'augmenter une sortie du four
effectivement la période de repos est
absolument primordial vous fait subir à
la viande un grand stress thermique
lorsqu'yves à recycler je vous
concentrez puis sont les pelouses fait
pas reposer comme il faut lui prendront
pas leur place dans l'alliance et des
jeux
la plupart des modèles ont bien fait
leur travail certains modèles ont par
contre des plus à notre chef le cdn qui
ne s'éteint pas sans enlever les piles
le masterchef qui semblait fragile et le
napoli c'est pas grâce à lui j'ai moi
même un point pour être franc je trouve
que la construction est assez
rudimentaire
aussi je trouvais qu'ils étaient
difficiles à programmer
en conclusion les trois préférés sont le
doc de towers à qtel et ricardo
[Musique]